[Música]
hablamos de economía en directo américa
de france24 está con nosotros en el
estudio de daniela landon dan y vamos a
hablar de las relaciones entre eeuu y
china que entran en una nueva etapa de
tensión así es de raúl muy buenos días
pues este martes entra en vigor una
prohibición estadounidense a las
importaciones desde la región de
xinjiang esta provincia noroccidental
china produce alrededor del 85 por
ciento del algodón del país ahora las
empresas deberán demostrar que lo que
importan no proviene del trabajo forzoso
de la comunidad uigur y es que china
está acusada de detener a personas de
esta minoría étnica en campos de
entrenamiento a obligándolos a trabajar
por apenas una fracción del salario
mínimo
y danny le pregunto entonces cuáles son
los efectos económicos de la huella de
transportadores en reino unido ya
cambiando de tema como también lo
conversamos con nuestra corresponsal
luisa pulido bueno pues este paro ocurre
cuando los costos de la energía se han
duplicado en el último año y la
inflación es la mayor en 40 años veamos
más en el siguiente informe
decenas de miles de personas salieron a
las calles de londres para protestar
contra la congelación salarial y los
recortes de empleo en el sector público
entre ellos está matt harding que lleva
25 años conduciendo los trenes del metro
de londres la huelga es la única forma
que tiene de hacer oír su voz a los
trabajadores del ferrocarril o cualquier
otro necesitan al menos un 10% para
mantenerse en contacto con la inflación
y creo que está está muy por debajo de
lo que la gente necesita como conductor
marcan a casi seis mil euros al mes un
buen sueldo pero ese es el doble de los
ingresos medios de un trabajador
ferroviario
si se van a recortar miles y miles de
puestos de trabajo de mantenimiento y se
van a subcontratar a personas menos
formadas va a ser un peligro es cara vía
callao
marc se jubila en agosto con 60 años son
los más jóvenes los que le preocupan
el gobierno el señor boris johnson
quiere cerrar el fondo de pensiones este
hombre quiere impedir que la gente se
retire del metro con dignidad
las conversaciones entre las empresas
ferroviarias y el principal sindicato se
han estancado
nuestras compañías operadoras de trenes
no lo han anunciado pero van a cerrar
todas las taquillas de todas las
estaciones de reino unido me lo han
dicho cara a cara quieren recortar la
restauración el personal de los trenes
no podemos aceptarlo esta economía y
este perro carril van hacia atrás para
muchos de estos manifestantes la huelga
es ahora la única orden del día aunque
los usuarios del transporte paguen el
precio
bueno angeli le pregunto por qué la
empresa google es noticia esta semana
pues él raúl en la empresa filial de
alphabet la estadounidense de gigante
tecnológica está siendo noticia por
todos lados miren francia la
multinacional aceptó pagar a los medios
de comunicación por los contenidos que
distribuye en sus buscadores después de
haber sido multada el año pasado por
incumplir la ley sobre este aspecto con
unos 500 millones de dólares y también
después de tres años de negociación al
respecto en alemania por su parte la
autoridad antimonopolio inició una
investigación por posibles restricciones
anticompetitivas en la plataforma google
maps porque al parecer
lo que estaría haciendo google es
restringiendo la combinación de sus
servicios de mapas con las de otras
aplicaciones y violando así
supuestamente la ley google en rusia
también entró en cesación de pagos hace
unos días y the new york times publicó
un informe el fin de semana según el
cual los usuarios empresariales tendrán
que comenzar a pagar un cargo mensual de
alrededor de 6 dólares por cada correo
de gmail y otras aplicaciones como
google docs y calmar a quienes no se
cambien voluntariamente antes del 27 de
junio lo harán automáticamente y si no
lo hacen se suspenderán sus cuentas a
partir de agosto esto según este diario
estadounidense que haría usted si le
cobrará por la cuenta de gmail no se le
pagaría porque sí porque es el correo
que uno usa todos los días que va y le
llegan todo pues como perderla pues los
emprendedores están bastante molestos
porque dicen que están de alguna manera
incumpliendo lo que les tienen desde un
principio que era que la cuenta iba a
ser gratis 100% gratis pero pues el
dinero siempre de por medio indicadores
económicos daniela bueno las bolsas
asiáticas suben un día después de que
china mantuviera tipos de interés se
están recuperando las acciones globales
después de el día festivo lunes en wall
street no pero el mismo comportamiento
se notó en las acciones europeas
pendientes de las decisiones que sigan
tomando los bancos centrales y le tengo
también una buen noticia bursátil y es
que la multinacional estadounidense
kellogg la de los hojuelas de maíz dijo
este martes que se van a dividir en tres
compañías separadas con diferentes
enfoques unas refrigerios otras cereales
y otros productos basados en plantas y
esto hizo que las acciones de la empresa
subieron un 7% en las operaciones
previas a la apertura del mercado cifra
el día danny para vuelo 883 25 pesos
chilenos este lunes se registró un nuevo
máximo histórico del dólar por segundo
día consecutivo en chile ante el
retroceso del valor del cobre que es
recordemos su principal producto de
exportación
danny como siempre muchísimas gracias
por toda la información nosotros más
adelante con más economía nosotros
continuamos en directo américa